so part two of our discussion of the
absolutely dystopian Trump rally in
Tulsa Oklahoma
over the weekend is the attendees yes
there weren't that many of them despite
their predictions and we're going to
talk about that later on but check out
some of these interviews with people who
went there to support Donald Trump now
now I do feel the need to issue a
disclaimer here the goal here isn't to
make fun of people the goal is to remind
you some of these people vote not all of
them but some of these people vote and
when I explained week after week after
week why it's so important to get out
the vote in November this is going to
remind us of the importance because a
ton of these trumpets when you see them
talk you're going to realize that what
I've been saying is true they can't be
talked out of voting for Donald Trump
these are the people that we are talking
about when I say would it be easier to
get five leftist friends to vote people
who are not usually voters and just say
hey it's really important that you vote
would that be easier or would it be
easier to convince one of these people
I'm about to show you to vote and you
will very quickly see these are not
people you can talk sense into so the
context here remember is corona virus is
spreading wildly in Oklahoma and other
red states a huge part of the country
doesn't seem to believe it or believe
that it's that serious or believe that
it warrants social distancing and a lot
of those exact same people are the ones
that approve of the job that Donald
Trump is doing the ones saying I like
what he's doing I believe he's doing a
good job so let's start with Rosie
Matlock
check this out she waited in line for
four days remember the stadium was
two-thirds empty why you would wait in
line for four days anyway is a question
why you would do it when the stadium is
two-thirds empty well she was
propagandized by Donald Trump about a
million requests for tickets and she was
interviewed by Andrew Kimmel this is
fascinating she's asked why have you
been sleeping in the chair for four days
waiting for Trump and she says well he
risk his whole life for us so I'm here
which almost suggests she's agreeing
that there's a risk to her
life from being at the rally right maybe
I'm missing the interpretation here but
let's take a look at it together from
and when when did you start waiting in
line Wednesday so what brought you to
come out on Wednesday and are you
sleeping out here you've been sleeping
in a chair that is devotion and so you
know what what is it that makes you want
to sleep on the street sit in a chair
for three nights now so that's weird
and this next moment is just great this
is still Andrew Kimmel interviewing her
Rosie Matlock says what could get you to
not vote for Trump in other words is
there a hypothetical where if Trump did
X X would mean you don't vote for Trump
and she says well if he cheated on
Melania which of course Donald Trump did
and check out the direction this goes is
there anything that Trump can do that
would make you lose your support
classy life she's amazing she is what
every American first lady should be well
what about the stormy Daniels thing
because he was married to her at that
time that was years ago before he ever
became president
nobody is accountable for what he done
when he was a lot younger oh okay Trump
was cheating on Melania but when he was
in his 60s now Trump is president as a
70 plus year old man you can't hold him
accountable for that this is gold
because we often talk about asking
trumpets this question what would make
you not support Trump she identifies
something that would make her not
support Trump cheating on Melania and
Andrew Kimmel points out well but he did
that and she says well yeah but that was
before he was President of the United
States if he cheated on Melania now I
wouldn't vote for him you cannot
convince them do not even bother do not
waste your time please let's continue
here's at rumpus inside the rally asked
about virus concerns says he's not
worried because he he can always take
hydroxychloroquine and take a look I'm
not concerned about the spread I think
in the general population I'm seeing
NUCCA 0.4 0.2 percent mortality rate
even if you got it you're not worried
about no and even if I did get sick from
it I mean there's so many positive
studies with the hydrofluoric Queen and
zinc rod the FDA got rid they said you
can't prescribe it for them
no the FDA saying that it is able to be
prescribed they only shut it down for a
certain for a certain thing and actually
in Trump's roundtable the other day they
explained it very well so of course this
guy is wrong the emergency use
authorization was shut down patients on
hydroxychloroquine were not doing well
it's not working and what happened in
the roundtable is that Alexei czar
simply said it might work if taken
earlier we don't have any evidence of
that but that's what was set at the
round table so again important these
folks don't even comprehend what it is
that is said Alex a czar was lying when
he said this stuff in other words the
idea that they're optimistic about
giving it earlier there's no evidence of
that but it doesn't matter because
people like this voter will hear
whatever it is that they want to hear
here's another dude who has a friend who
died of coronavirus his friend's kid was
on a ventilator but here he is without a
mask around people without masks as
cases rage in Oklahoma his friend died
son on a ventilator almost died but we
don't know what the facts are well what
what are we talking about exactly I mean
is it a fact that your friend died is it
a fact that your friend's kid was on a
ventilator and then the motivated
reasoning is just fascinating listen I
know people who are concerned and
they're around groups of people without
wearing a mask so that must be evidence
that's okay that it's okay to do the
thing I want to do anyway but are we
talking about that being
at a rally of 6,200 people that seems a
little different and then here's the
cherry on top here's a guy who says that
Barack Obama assured in Marxism and says
how on earth did anyone vote for anyone
named Obama anyway oh and by the way
Obama also wasn't Obama's real name I
walked away from the Republicans back in
2006 once we gave him a trifecta from Oh
for 206 they spent like drunken sailors
and they became you know basically
Democrats so I walked away from him back
then you know then they you know half
the country's wealth was stolen in broad
daylight you know September of Oh nine
nobody goes to jail except Bernie Madoff
and he was stealing from his own people
then of course they ushered in Obama to
normalize Marxism in the United States
of America teamed up for Hillary to do a
sin you know I just you know you think
it'd be common sense you wouldn't vote
for a guy named Obama for President of
the United States particularly since
that wasn't even his real name but you
know Marxist Obama whose real name
wasn't Obama never should have been
elected on the basis of claiming to be
named Barack Obama it's interesting if
you're going to lie about your name
wouldn't you pick something that would
not be a turn-off to a large swath of
this country that is xenophobic and
racist and pick something other than
Barack Obama like as a fake name Barack
Obama seems like a horrible idea seems
Martin Smith might have been a smarter
fake name to take if that was the idea
so we can't convince them this is more
proof we've got to get out the vote
don't even waste energy just focus on
getting out the vote in the key
battleground in swing states we know
which ones they are we know which states
are likely to determine who is the
electoral college Victor in November and
that's where we have to focus let me
know what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman remember that we have a daily
audio podcast which you can get for free
on any of your favorite podcasting apps
leave us a review if you please on
iTunes stitcher Spotify pick
you're poison all of them are available
we'll take a quick break more on the
rally attendance and Trump's rage at the
empty seats coming up after the break